[Music]
welcome to the iron lords podcast
all right and we are live laura coghido
here ilovepodcastclawsongaming.net
and who is this fine best dressed
gentleman of tax west today who's the
greatest person in the world
uh i'm paul engel i work for taylor's
entertainment as a producer um we are
here to present the game mount flight
van awards a mount lake 2 vandal
it's been out on pcs for some time now
but we wanted to present it to people on
consoles as well
right now we're in early access on steam
gog epic
uh and by october 25th uh people will be
able to get the full release on all
platforms and includes ps4 ps5
xbox one
xbox and xbox
let's get right into mountain blade too
all right hey let's take a look at it
huh so you want me to play yes you want
the expert
okay fair enough uh just as a quick
rundown the camo demo is actually the
the full game uh what we've done is
we've added this free selection of
characters so people can jump right into
it they don't have to go through
character creation all that
uh ali jin and the others are returners
of the previous sort of demos from
gamescom et cetera
i think they've done three to three
rounds already three tours
two actions
uh they've grown older uh every time
they're well equipped well skip skills
all that
stuff and uh well they have different
starting positions they all have this
sort of similar setup uh with one siege
a big field battle and a small field
battle so what's the general like theme
of batman like what what is the whole is
it like war or kingdoms or we like
what's going on in this world well a bit
of everything yeah um fundamentally
mount plate is a sort of massive
medieval simulator
strategy elements you've got action
elements and you've got rpg elements
in terms of massive like this is how we
started to then right let's zoom out of
it
oh wow
wow this is the world of call radio you
can conquer all this if you want to so
yes it's definitely a war game
but
you do have a number of different since
it is a sandbox you have a number of
different activities that you can pursue
you're not tasked to necessarily conquer
everything you can be a merchant if you
want to you can help people with their
issues through quest
uh and so on and so forth
we have our siege here in a field battle
here i think i'll try to start with the
field battle because
quicker and
yeah give us some some uh opportunity
and while you're traveling here see
these three kind of icons
exactly this this is uh
another thing that so one of the things
that i want to show here is we have
these different control modes this
allows us to travel this allows us to
uh select the ui elements we have the
joystick for that
but we can also use the d-pad to like
quickly jump between things i think the
ui team has some really nice idea here
i'm personally not a huge console player
yeah but i can actually figure this out
but it's a it's funny you say that
because i am and one of the bigger
fairies of entry for me for like any
like rcs or these type of big type scale
games is that the interface sometimes is
not intuitive and that actually seemed
intuitive like yeah yeah and i was like
press fly all right cool that that is
actually helpful to get us into the
space that's great to hear because one
of the reasons like why we wanted to
bring this to these events is just to
get people's impressions on the controls
it's not
um you know the typical console game
but it does offer something new and i
think it is
something that is good that we're
pushing into the console market um not
just for us but for for that market as
well to give a greater variety
so you can just click on these for
example this just basically helps people
get into the demo a bit faster find the
locations that they need to be we don't
necessarily even have to do these
um
but it's the easiest way to get into a
battle and show you some of the action
and the visuals
and that was just like an army that
we're choosing what are we what are we
doing right now we're choosing
we're helping you guys exactly so
we're the uh
khan of the uh zane actually uh jin has
just been um chosen by the cruel type
uh
and she's here to prove herself so as to
speak
and this screen is the pre-metal uh
deployment screen uh when you're more
like deep in the game this becomes a
strategy layer yeah basically allows you
to like deploy the different troops if
you're in charge of their battle it
allows you to assign captains which have
benefits i wanted to play with him you
look vicious
well because we're helping somebody else
actually i'm sorry
we can choose our own information
because we have a high ranking as the
king for calm
um so we're taking care of the uh the
cavalry here because we also have yeah
um and
if you like check these guys out they
also have a better effect so both um
based on their
skills
and their equipment they can benefit
their information so you can create
these characters over time
to allow you to have like a really
effective instructor captain or archery
captain et cetera
if you don't want to deal with it as
well though you just need to do the skip
formation
and we're right in the game
and yeah i mean this is one of the sort
of unique selling points i'd say for the
game definitely
it's just massive uh in terms of the
amount of troops that are available to
us here uh this is with the control
scheme as you can see
just the left one here
and it goes into slow-mo so we actually
have a lot of time to figure things out
there's three sort of fundamental
control schemes one is for the uh
movement one is for the formation and
one is for the toggle toggle things like
fire will hold your fire etc
so let's choose the uh you know movement
i want them to uh follow me
let's go just go like this and let go
yep i'll see they do
i'm loving this scale this is a unique
approach to this this cinematic style
i'm really liking it oh let's just seize
them yes let's go
he did not survive yeah he did that's
about it
he was a banner bearer so one of the
this is one of the things that we have
in this demo panel actually has banners
now and these come with gameplay effects
as we talked about a moment ago
and if you like uh as you get rid of
these vanna bearers here information
actually loses um that matter this is a
nice little thing as well you can see
that there's some sense to what the ai
is doing they've placed their archers on
top of the hill the infantry in front
recovery to the side to be able to flank
because the need arises
and all of our guys are with us
i don't really want to deal with them
right now because it's going to distract
me
i'm going to actually show the toggle
so here if i just want to fight right i
can delegate command to the ai
and i don't have to deal with them
anymore
this way i can just focus on the action
aspect
uh
and this yeah it allows players to
choose what they prefer right if they
want to deal with the commanding great
they can if they just want to play
great
so you can pretty much control your
level of interactivity and what you want
to control with those type of commands
yeah exactly
so
right now
you can also choose different weapons
etc as well
this again goes with the slow-mo so
just to put the head here uh or stay
connected right you're good and uh
actually
okay cool we can switch to first person
holding this toggle we can zoom in with
that toggle so we go from
[Music]
it's not necessarily the best for like
while you're on the horse some people
like it um but it's like really useful
and features when you're trying to like
hit the guys in the murder holes and all
that stuff
nice
again it's like it's a very interactive
system in terms of balance which i kind
of like because it gives you that sense
of scale of good or big war when you're
out in the field and stuff like that
that's really good yeah if you just look
at this um
it's a thousand uh agents that can be
active at the same time this is the same
for gen 9 as it is for pc okay which uh
so right now we're playing on the xbox x
right
so
there are two different uh
uh performance modes sort of okay in
modality mode uh the one that we're
applying with the thousand agents goes
up to 30 fps okay uh i think it is in 4k
okay and then if you want to have 60 fps
it goes down to six actually so what's
cool though to give it that flexibility
right if someone's uh you know i tend to
be at 60 fps now so you got the option
but if someone wants that fidelity in
that 4k you got the 4k 30 option a
little bit more graphical fidelity
i do believe most players will
want the large battles yeah because
that's kind of one of the things that
we're really known for
so the large battle which you say is not
available in the other mode the
performance mode is that exclusive to
the
well it's still large up to 600 people
right um which is closer than the
previous games i think they were kept in
like a hundred on consoles uh at warband
um so definitely an improvement in any
case uh fourth gen eight as well uh it
is larger than warband at 250 in sieges
and 400 in
field battles but if you want to have
the the massive experience then yeah you
would need to go with the gen
we will continue to improve performance
of course and see what we can push
but of course we want to have a stable
experience
as well so we have to be a bit careful
this is really this is really cool and
again the large scale battles you have
that interactivity you have the option
to you know simulate and control every
aspect of it like what would you say as
far as like
gameplay length
two questions one
gameplay length overall like how many
hours can you sink into battle this
looks like very extensive um
we'll jump back
before from this
battle for parameters
and
just have another look at the map
gameplay some players spend thousands of
hours yes um
i think you can probably
get through the main storyline uh within
a couple dozen hours um
the most of the length there as well
comes from the interaction with the
sandbox right as you progress the
storyline uh you have to
fight uh within the sandbox context so
there can be lots of things that
you may not expect
so we didn't finish that battle but they
were largely done um so since you can
come for all this right uh it just
is
very time intense potentially very time
intensive um and if you enjoy the
gameplay luke that's great um
the
what about like the main press like you
want to get for a guy like me let's say
okay
kind of don't say new to his face but
these are not the ones that games i
generally gravitate towards because
sometimes i get overwhelmed by paralysis
by analysis so what about like the main
quest like so far okay what's the things
i would do to know to notify you notify
me that this is made by storyline that's
going towards the progression of the
game that's 15 to 16 hours ago i think
it would still be 60 to maybe 100
because the way that this game is set up
so for the demo um it can be a bit
overwhelming for people but of course we
don't have the time to like build
everything up
you start as an individual like just by
yourself okay so the scope of
progression that the game offers is
uh
really quite unique i think in terms of
all of the different uh social stations
that you go through
um so you start by yourself maybe hire a
couple troops start trading start
hunting bandits become maybe a mercenary
engage in tournaments engage in quests
maybe become a vessel then you become a
king potentially as well and as you do
so you can create your own kingdom or
you can like support and exist we're
really starting from the ground level to
build up so i'm assuming at this stage
we're further advanced in the game yeah
at this stage this is like mid to i mean
since ali jin's character is
the leader of the faction
it's entering late game
sort of
she only owns this part of the map
and just taking the rest of this here
um i think i need to go into another so
that's the red festival thank you the
breakfast actually indicates there's a
rebellion here or
not
so when
all the um
towns have some uh parameters like
loyalty and security uh they're affected
by things like you know as their
starvation going on because there's a
deep
simulation of the economy here as well
with the villages during the raw
production
and
supplying the towns the towns processing
them caravans going around distributing
them
which the player can interact with uh so
yeah if the town is unhappy they might
just say
we're done
exactly they create a new plan and
if they survive a certain amount of time
they'll then become a proper clan join
attraction
and uh or kingdom and um just uh
continue to play to play uh as you would
normally as well
a lot of depth
um yeah like if we look at the personal
uh progression here as well
um so this is what you and every other
character does you have a bunch of
attributes i think it's about 18 skills
here and each of the skills is another
20 perks that you you know choose in
between uh as you progress that skill
the fundamental approach here is sort of
learning by doing so if i'm using a lot
of one-handed weapons i'll grow
there are certain limits to my
effective growth that are affected by
focus points and attributes
distribution so this is something that
the player can kind of
weigh into well absolutely i'm
definitely feeling that aspect and the
scale is way bigger than i thought
the other thing as well here is this is
this is your character but you're
actually playing as a clan so you have a
bunch of characters that you get to
level um if we go over and check out the
clan
this is our family right now right we
can have we can get married we can have
children we can die he's about to ask
you that yeah we can continue as our
children
and so forth
we can also hire some companions and so
on and so forth trade plan parties we
can own thieves and manage them and
assign a governor send our members there
we can own workshops we have some
supporters out of the notable characters
as we fulfill quests we increase
relations and then
some of the locals will start to say hey
you're a pretty cool guy
uh let's
let's help you out
all right all right okay
i'll just jump into the seats full view
yeah let's see let's see
let's go let's see this is really cool
man you guys got it's way more expensive
than i thought i i thought it was what
simple it is actually a deeper gameplay
level than i thought and a lot of
simulation management that i didn't
realize
um the good thing is like you're not hit
with it right away right you're you're
since you're starting to nobody slowly
like even if you wanted to engage with
all of those elements you just wouldn't
have the resources
so
it feels kind of natural i think
for the most part as you progress you
learn
new things and yeah i mean the sieges
are one of those things as well i just
chose not to command anything then i
will take care of it you can take you
know control of that manganal for
example and do that shot yourself
your ai mates will start pushing these
melee siege engines to the front we got
do we got the chippy shoes do we got the
chickens here we can build them yes yeah
you don't have to do it
right there
yes you can build trebuchets uh but
actually manganals might work uh better
against uh troops because they are
coming in we're coming in to seize them
let's go
see that just hit our guys pretty hard
all of this redstone oh yeah that's not
good
i don't think they're about that okay so
with it within the mission for instance
there are certain elements of the wall
that can be destroyed like the merlin's
here uh on the world map there's also a
compartment place where you can actually
destroy the the the wall so there will
be a bridge okay uh then you don't need
a siege tower anymore um but that's more
of a time investment right as you shoot
back and forth also
right now this is not good
um you know that's the cost of the
settlement
right oh you're one of those leaders
okay i'll see i'll see what's going on
they're dying for the greater good
yeah as they approach they'll open up
the the seed star climate uh when the uh
ram gets to the
gate as well
we'll start dragging it
um there's the secondary gate within you
know with uh sort of a
i'm not sure what you call it actually
but um they can throw stones from up
above as your men are like happening at
the gate so there's a lot
yeah there's a lot of stories in there i
you don't know what will happen at any
given stage uh players can experience
something pretty
fun or you know um so would you say that
is it i want to say procedurally
generated but it there's a randomization
nature too as far as like how the
reactions are oh yeah based on the
conditions yeah um the
aia ships as well
they all have through their individual
logic their part of information that
tries to so this guy will go up over the
gate and then all the others will follow
yeah he's a
kind of a
brave individual um
they getting it over there
now they're they're tearing up and then
they'll start going up there
um
so so information will will tell them
okay we want to take the gate we want to
take the wall all that good stuff but
the agent themself you know based on
their morale they might say well you
know
mango doll just hit all five of my
friends i'm out of here i'm leaving
so that's one of the cool things right
you're not just fighting these blocks of
of uh enemies um you're or actually
fighting individuals that will try and
you know block you as well oh there you
go that's uh okay that's [ __ ] out
that's what's like this is the best
thing just getting dance on that's all
they're doing
right now this is sort of the mosh pit
over here so uh we're going to
they are trying to hold this thing
exactly they are not going down but they
apparently are not blocked anymore we
just got to
fold on our shoulder
um
that was lucky yeah
wow
getting crazy right there get crazy this
morning what i can try and do is
shoot them down of course
yeah yeah he's a rude individual yeah
they try to defended me
they don't want to be sneezed
okay
as you can see you know as as this
believe happens you still have the range
comment going on as well
um
if this tower takes too much damage
everyone on it is going to suffer
we're all going to drop down and die but
let's hope that doesn't happen
so yeah as you get into this it is
hacked jim
you're just one of many that's one of
the things that
okay i did survive so that's good um
uh
question so based on like i said if
you've got all the ai you can only
from your advantage point i get it
can you you're locked to that vent but
i'm assuming as opposed to being able to
switch to other
players other aspects of your army i'm
assuming you control
yourself for the most part okay um
right now our approach is that we do not
have this body shifting
um
it's an interesting idea we've actually
had that discussion
today with someone oh yeah
um we do that at our multiplayer mode so
this game also has a multiplayer
there's a we call it captain mode and
players have a
2230 like troops to command 6v6 and it's
very accessible because
when you run into a situation where
um
you die you just continue with your
troops right so that's uh that's pretty
nice um so so i guess my question is the
fail state just want to be quickly
honest yeah before you rap like if you
die
then what happened if the army is still
alive
um it can help i think you can have an
impact when on like the morale but the
army can still win if they you know
don't break out
and um
if you die
completely uh you either have to have an
air to continue or it's game over uh
that would be a game overstay if there's
no hair yes got it um
as for the other question with like the
body shifting etc yeah i think that can
be explored as a sort of difficulty
option for the game uh because i mean
one of the things that sets us apart i
suppose is that you know we're not
superman we're not superwoman uh we're
just one of many i'm about to die
actually i mean
he's down
so we do you know still have the option
to like play around
with the walk it's still going on right
obviously
yeah i can toggle this as fast forward
as well which will be a bit shocky but
it's a lot of agents
um
if we don't want to deal with these
battles as well we can just jump out
and simulate the rest of it within a
second
um but yeah so if you know we have that
body shifting i think at least the
emotion of our players want it to be
optional right to have that sort of more
hardcore experience um yeah this is how
we can agree
that could be an option at the
difficulty level we've got multiplayer
right we've got multiplayer okay for pc
we've also got a really talented um
modding community that has a lot of uh
access to the game they are probably
gonna make all kinds of crazy mods of
course uh one of the things that is cool
uh like you know if you have a strong pc
you can up the battle size even more i
think up to two
um that's something that we don't do
because
well there's a chance for instability at
that point as well and we need to like
guarantee that absolutely absolutely as
much as we can that people have a
stability couple of other questions how
long have you been in development
okay that's uh that's a subjective
question i would say um so the game's
been in development for has been
announced uh i think back in 2012 so
we're like
if you found it as a starting point for
like 10 years it's been in early access
since two years
and uh yeah we will probably still
develop it after the you know release as
well and it don't just mean bug fixes i
mean
including content updates
we already have uh announced certain
plans like we want to add some
voiceovers for the great things right
maybe for the storyline uh we want to
explore things like an additional sort
of cell so we're still adding we're
still building okay gotcha
uh we are excited about the ideas that
our players have about the ideas that we
have
and uh i think we will continue uh for
some time to cover so anyone wants to
know about vanderlord where can they go
if they want to get more information on
the game
and how like i said to learn everything
that you guys do
uh well we do have uh our official
website so
tailwiz.com there's also the forums
there if you want to engage with us
directly you can follow us on social
media you can check us out on youtube
that's the social media
i don't know offense i'm sorry we'll get
it for you we'll put it in the video
don't worry it'll be in the description
um
yeah so on steam of course as well we
share our regular updates there and all
the other uh uh platforms like
applicants here and coffee will come in
the casa right
october 25th uh all of the uh you know
ps4 ps5 xbox one xbox and xbox
one final question on the cross
iteration on multiplayer would it be
cross-generational multiplayer and
cross-play or no uh
yes it will be
cross-generational but you won't be able
to play like on the playstation xbox or
actually
for ps4 ps5
yeah ps4 ps5 is fine got it you heard it
first better lord like i said still
working he still got things cooking
still a lot of ideas going on an
absolute pleasure to check it out with
you guys you heard it here first check
it out man
[Music]
you